maybe there's some centrifugal force
right is this something you can grab
stranger walks into a bar and says I bet
$20 then no we can get the cork out of
this empty bottle of wine without
breaking the bottle using nothing but a
plastic bag after that would fail let's
try some little fast and suction feel
like this has something to do with
science is this here for a reason yeah
[Music]
[Music]
my finger is not long enough to reach it
well I don't know why I would think
putting in a bag would do anything felt
like it was doing something for a second
air and bottle maybe I'd be able to
figure this out but drink some actual
wine before this is this doing anything
I want to break it click put it in here
somehow this doesn't work at all I'm not
doing anything I really wanted a torque
can't grab the bottle
feel really dumb it's possible that I
can pull this thing out the cork will
come with it I surrender I give up I'm
waving it I literally don't know how you
do it
[Music]
step one shove a cork into an empty wine
bottle
step two grab a plastic bag step three
push the closed end of the bag into the
bottle
step four inflate the bag while making
sure the cork is near the neck of the
bottle step 5
pull the bag out of the bottle step 6
collect your money
[Music]
[Music]
Oh